well with a big group of people today
we're going to
the
high score camp
which is where they are doing a
uh ice coring drilling project
oh cool everything you see in cardboard
tubes is what we dr as what we've
drilled this year um and that was when
we were in the brittle ice so it's
fragile ice we put it in some green
netting in case it pops or breaks so
this will sit over a year and then we'll
come back and process it next year um
but just yesterday we started actually
processing the ice it turned out that
it's uh sturdy enough that we can cut it
and it won't
bust into a million pieces so that's
what you'll see in like 30 seconds up
there so probably want to head up
because we can see the jewel coming out
of the hole which is really cool
this is so dramatic
what is the vacuum for uh to get all the
liquid off the table uh okay
looks like just a long candy bar
look it
oh look at that oh man those are the
cutters
so the piece of ice that they just
pulled out was pulled up from about a
little over a thousand meters
below
the surface
of the uh of the snow here
and they think it's about twenty
thousand years old
that that snow was deposited twenty
thousand years ago it's pretty cool and
then they store it here and then after
storing it here supposedly they ship it
to a place where they study
the ice the bubbles in the ice
and the
the water
and the dust this is the motor
instrument section here okay this is
essentially the brain okay the drill
okay the idea is 100 recovery of the
ships collected but that doesn't work
but then what'd you do with them um you
actually put them through the centrifuge
which is the blue tango okay there okay
spin out all the fluid and capture that
okay plum it back down the bore hole
whoop so where is it 1100 which means
like a little a little short of 20 000.
nice
and i mean it's super exponential then
yeah as you go to sixteen thousand to
sixteen hundred meters yeah fifty
thousand years old
pretty cool that's pretty amazing like
our total turnaround time from taking
the drill down drilling bring it up and
then clean it up process it and put it
back down it's been about one hour and
15 minutes okay this is by far the
lowest pr part of the process it's
tripping down
tripping up and go a lot faster
oh yeah
i get my priorities
this is all the sludge that is all the
chips
looks like vanilla ice cream
something like that
is really cool it's a vacuum cleaner
that has the shape of the core yeah well
all the
customers
originally it was
flat
you can't buy that from hoover
it's so cool
hi did you enjoy that video
well make sure to check out more of
those videos
in the video description below or on the
links on the screen
see you later